avec le co vide le cinéma est il perdu
la guerre contre les plateformes
ça c'est la grosse question je me fonde
essentiellement sur les études du
ministère de la culture sur les
pratiques culturelles des français menée
depuis des années par olivier donnat qui
montrent en réalité que les pratiques
culturelles sur le numérique ne sont pas
nécessairement antinomiques ne sont pas
nécessairement contradictoires des
pratiques classiques à d'autres termes
ya même des hypothèses de synergies et
s'agissant des plateformes de diffusion
du cinéma
il ne me semble pas que la bataille soit
perdue pour la fréquentation des salles
car évidemment d'abord qui vit dans la
taille de l'écran puis la pratique
culturelle qui est une pratique
collective partagée qui renvoie l'aspect
ludique qu'on n'a pas de manière
individuelle sur des plateformes me
laisse espérer qu'on n'est plus dans des
logiques de superposition des pratiques
culturelles plutôt que de substitution
donc pour répondre très directement à
votre question
moi qui ne suis pas de tempérament
optimiste je ne suis pas très pessimiste
sur l'avenir du cinéma en salle
non non non
au moment